[Music]
we've new wheels a pre celebration for
the big day huh
I make your partner baby break that
glass ceiling who deserves this give it
up summit worldwide sports management's
newest partner boys club every days you
don't connect well with men just stay in
your lane I don't trust women who don't
get dudes like I don't trust a man with
no eyebrows are too many keys I know
someone you should talk to
I can help you commit with me why don't
we have some tea this is nice like dirt
oh that's just jasmine tea if you don't
count the weeds and the peony okay
[Applause]
oh hello welcome back miss Davis thank
god this one's in died on me
starting today no more drinking at work
hey that's so much information or
anything I feel we here too after last
night yeah that's what happens when
tequila meets and desperation okay stop
saying things it shouldn't be saying to
your boss holy crap can you hear my
inner thoughts
I can only hear mean stuff that cloud
you're walking through that's my farts I
thought black people stopped when ETS or
get out
where would you complain about men
trying to keep you down do we have any
readings on the books nothing yet except
the private poker game tonight
this is not a curse Pasha tech badass
the lady which doing it the big boys
table huh too quiet
I'm bluffing these Falls I'm missing
Real Housewives check finally has a
winning hand
why am I thinking in the third person I
smell toast my happiness throw weight I
have chosen my pocket
[Music]
[Applause]